the craziest thing that took place at
Capitol Hill yesterday was the UFO
hearing and
I went in and I wanted to keep an open
mind and you know we've had some debates
about aliens at the daily wire I
cannot overstate just how stupid these
hearings are I predicted they would be
stupid I tried to keep it they're G it's
so dumb and so
obviously fake
but let's hear them out uh first clip
from Congressman Tim burchett asking
and this is a very serious question
has anyone been injured or harmed
retrieving or even covering up the
supposed alien spacecraft
do you have any personal knowledge of
people have been harmed or injured in
efforts to cover up or conceal these
extraterrestrial technology yes
personally
have you heard anyone been murdered that
you would think that you know of or have
heard of I guess I have to be careful
asking that question I directed people
with that knowledge to the appropriate
authorities maybe in a um if we could
get it get in a confidential area skiff
we could talk about that but
unfortunately
we were denied access to the skiff
and that's very unfortunate in this in
this scenario
skiff is a secure setting where you can
talk about sensitive information the
implication here
is that
either aliens have murdered Americans
American servicemen and other government
workers
or that the government has murdered
Americans for knowing too much about
aliens that the implication here is
every sci-fi horror alien movie come to
life that's the implication I use that
word carefully it's an implication
because
we don't have any names we don't have
any dates we don't have any evidence we
just have this guy's testimony I am not
questioning the guy's Integrity I'm not
saying he's lying I just can't help but
notice we talked about this on the show
yesterday
every single time we've we've got the
Smoking Gun we've got proof of an alien
and UFOs and flying saucers
we don't get it we don't get the details
we just get insinuations and
implications and trust me I know you got
to trust me if only we could get into
the skiff if only I could tell you what
happened if only I could give you names
if only I could give you details so this
is amazing Brighton circuses TV that the
American public is gobbling up I'm
talking about it right now on the show
so I guess it worked but is there any
actual substance to what they're saying
Anna Paulina Luna Republican Congressman
asks if
the man testifying has ever feared for
his life following up on this question
of have people been murdered in these
cover-ups have people been injured
here's his answer
in the last couple of years have you had
incidences that have caused you to be in
fear for your life for addressing these
issues
yes personally
yeah I just want everyone to note that
he's coming forward in fear of his life
to put in perspective if they were
really not scared about this information
coming out why would someone be
intimidated like that
okay maybe he is in fear of his life
look maybe it's real all right let's
just say maybe ET is real and we've got
all these aliens and spacecraft and
secret bunkers in area 51. okay
but again
where is the evidence this exchange
which is captivating and it's gone viral
and people are talking about it he this
man fears for his life what kind of
evidence is that the evidence being
presented here is a guy's feelings
I don't mean to mock his feelings but
when we're talking about Congressional
testimony when we're talking about the
little green men I would rather hear
some facts and details and evidence
because these kinds of insinuations can
be made about anything well yes I did
feel I felt very threatened this is what
the libs say on college campuses they
say I felt unsafe when you
called me by a pronoun that I don't like
and therefore I felt like it was really
dangerous and threatening feel feel you
can never disprove a feeling so I'm
really not mocking the guy I'm I I don't
mean to be harsh on him but
give me something if we're going to hold
this big circus hearing give me anything
real
right now go to ziprecruiter.com Knowles
if you're hiring you're probably dealing
with economic uncertainty now more than
ever it's important to hire the right
people faster and more efficiently to
keep overall costs down thankfully zip
recruiter is a hiring partner focused on
you and your needs from pricing to
technology everything that zip recruiter
does is for you and what works best for
you right now you can try them for free
at ziprecruiter.com Knowles zip
recruiters smart technology identifies
and matches for your job and lets you
invite candidates you really want to
apply to your job before other
businesses can snag them I love their
pricing it's super straightforward you
know what you pay before posting your
job so you can stick to your budget with
no surprises hire the best with the help
of a partner who's all about you with
zip recruiter four out of five employers
who post on ZipRecruiter get a quality
candidate within first day go to this
exclusive web address right now
ziprecruiter.com
Knowles try it for free that is
ziprecruiter.com slash
k-n-o-w-l-e-s ZipRecruiter the smartest
way
to hire Nancy mace got the closest I
think to An Answer another Republic
liberal Republican Congress lady Nancy
mace asks all right you're afraid for
your life you're saying people have been
threatened and harmed and injured and
all about this well do we have the goods
do we have spacecraft do we have alien
bodies and this answer
to me is the most telling of the entire
testimony though in a way that's
different from how most people are
interpreting it
if you believe we have crashed
it earlier do we have
piloted this craft
as I've stated publicly already in my
news Nation interview biologics came
with some of these recoveries yeah
um
were they I
like a human biologics
non-human and that was the assessment of
people with direct knowledge on the
program I talked to that are currently
still on the program in was this
documentary evidence is video photos
eyewitness like how would that be
determined
the specific documentation I would have
to talk to you in a skiff about
if only we got that skiff that would
have been nice the word that perked my
ears up here
biologics
the hell is biologics that's a weird
word that's a weird clinical jargony
word
that nobody really knows the meaning of
but did he did he mean bodies well he
would have just said bodies did he mean
tissue organs splattered alien guts no
biologics which is a term that when it
is used and it's used very rarely is
often used with regard to Medicine
it's not what does that mean man it was
non-human biologics okay
what could that could be anything you
could recover a craft that had some
other organism in it had a single cell
organism in it they said well that's
biologics we got it had some other kind
of tissue I don't know some guy had a
cat hair on him what what is it when are
we going to get specific now what the
man testifying here says is well I would
just need to be in a skiff to get
specific about that okay
can the congress not do it
can the congress not demand the
opportunity to to meet with this guy off
the Record in a skiff
Maybe not maybe maybe it is a super
duper deep secret cover-up and we've
been storing alien bodies and
refrigerators for a long time
but
what seems more likely to you
that E.T is real and in a bunker
somewhere Underground
or that the government is distracting
you
or that gullible people are following
fantasies or that
what that it at the moment that we've
got really pressing National matters
the U.S Congress and the bureaucracy are
putting on a bread and circuses show
that is succeeding because we're all
talking about it what do you seems more
the thing seems more likely
if it were the case
that it were the former if it were the
case that we really have all these alien
bodies
why have we never ever ever gotten even
one hard detail verifiable piece of
evidence about any of it in all the
decades that people have been talking
about it including the last few years
where it's really come up
what seems more likely to you I I think
I've got my answer Mr Walsh has his
answer
which side are you on pick a side man
you stand in the middle of the road
you're going to get hit by a UFO boy
what a great clip that was make sure
that you ring the bell subscribe to the
Michael Knowles YouTube channel
see you next time